Tâm Tâm I Tế Việt Nam, bình Việt tâm Anh thành vô chiming chính thức đưa vào hạt động sư mai chup CT hơn một trong những lá cắt,
zú phát hiện các dấu hiệu sớm của u tư. Đó quyết và nhiều bỉ lý mì hiếp khác. Đây là sư mai chup CT thứ 2 của hệ thống bệnh Việt tâm Anh chỉ sâu bốn tháng giám mắt mấy đầu tiên tại Hanoi.
Xeo mai CT này của háng Siem Anh theo thín dịch. Được, đưa đánh giá là vừa qua mọi dưới hạn về lá cắt mời sối lượng lá cắt gặp đại có thể đặt lên đến hơn một trong những lá cắt chỉ trong một lần chục với các yêu địa vượu.
Công nghệ giám điều tiê ít đến tâm em lắm phần chăm sói vời CT thông tường, ăn toàn với cả trẻ em, thậm chí trẻ sư dinh người ca tôi có nhiều bình nên.
Tụi bộ chục như nhất thế giới khi thup bản có thể chỉ trong chưa đầy hai giây, phần mình ấy ai sau định số lá cắt từ động sút đặt được hình anh xưa nét và lá cắt xưa mọng chỉ khu về bốn miệnh mét.
Zú phát hiện những tổng thường xưa nhỏ từ rất sớm với độ chính xác cao nhất từ trước đến này.
Zú phát hiện, người í dứt sớm và chính xác cao bất thường xưa nhỏ chỉ phải miếng mét từ mệt mấu nó, mệt bình tin, các hội u ở cất tạm như vụ,
lần thật rất hiểu ít và chính xác trong tầm sóc, và thịt sớm vui cơ được quyết, ông tư, mệt tin mạnh.
Có thể khẩu giá cắt đại anh anh vào bật chắc của các hội u, bố như phần bị khội u, các lại soại hiện tiếp nhận, phần bị tổng thường gần dây trang, khóc có phải từ bệnh của thay không,
và thịt gắt tổng thường nhỏ như chục lều thấp có tên tốt cảnh qua.
Chỉ vì hợp lý, bởi giá chỉ từ hai trở năng trong nghỉ đồng trong một lần chục.
Ngay tưởng hôm nay, mạnh biệt tâm anh thành vô chính mạnh sẽ chính thức đưa xưa máy cd và sử dụng trông đàn dạng trời khóa như tìm mạnh.
Ông bớt, thân tinh, tư hoa, khu hấp, cơ xương khấp, tích nụ, phục hoa, í khóa, lươi đặt lịch anh.